hoy en Río de Janeiro sus caricaturas
oficialmente para el segundo mandato
como presidente de Brasil en el complejo
del maracaná en el maracanáusiño un
estadio de voleibol casi lleno y lo hace
con su Estilo de siempre informal Antes
de hablar ha dejado el micrófono a su
esposa micheli que inicialmente no
quería involucrarse con la campaña pero
que he decidido hablar hoy en la ha
recordado La puñalada que recibió
durante la campaña de Hace cuatro años y
ha hecho un repaso de los que él
considera sus principales logros Como
por ejemplo la retomada de varias obras
públicas y la lucha contra la crisis
económica en medio de la pandemia lo que
hemos notado entre sus seguidores Es que
su discurso acabado porque los
seguidores revolucionaron en pesos creen
que él acaba con la corrupción y que no
consiguen gobernar como podría por causa
de la oposición supuestamente del
parlamento y del tribunal supremo